retour ici à besançon à la cité des arts
et de la culture où nous avons réuni
eric quelques-uns des principaux
candidats pour les élections régionales
pour premier grand débat de cette
campagne on discute depuis une heure
avec marie-guite dufay pour le ps cecile
prud'hommes pour europe ecologie les
verts nathalie vermorel
pour le parti communiste françois
sauvadet pour lui d y est les
républicains christophe grudler pour le
modem et sophie montel pour le front
national je rappelle qu'il ya quatre
autres listes annoncé jérémy maxime
chibout pour de vous la france charles
henri gallois pour l'upm plein rush et
pour lutte ouvrière et julien gonzalez
pour l'union écologiste indépendant
alors mesdames messieurs dans cette
deuxième partie on aimerait connaître
quelle sera votre première décision de
président ou de présidente
si vous êtes élu le 13 décembre prochain
on commence avec vous françois sauvadet
vous est élu président de la région
bourgogne franche comté qu'est-ce que
vous décidez en premier au 1er janvier
au 1er janvier un plan massif de
déploiement du très haut débit pour la
grande région bourgogne franche comté un
plan massif
d'ailleurs j'ai rencontré les présidents
de conseils départementaux qui vous le
savez sont eux qui vont pour l'essentiel
déployer concrètement les choses on a
pris la décision d'ailleurs ensemble de
créer une société publique locale de
commercialisation de la fibre à domicile
donc c'est une première étape il faut un
plan massif aujourd'hui pour l'instant
et pour les départements qui sont actifs
sur cette région département sont actifs
mais simplement vous avez vu les enjeux
financiers
c'est entre 150 millions et 220 millions
par département par département sur les
huit départements de la grande région à
l'exception de peut-être le territoire
de belfort qui avait déjà avancé
donc il faut un plan massif et donc la
deuxième chose que je ferai c'est
d'aller voir la banque européenne
d'investissement et nous doublerons jeu
les on attendait bien nous doublerons
les crédits actuellement pour le très
haut débit pour accélérer ce plan de
déploiement parce qu'il est
indispensable pour l'équilibré du
territoire pour les agriculteurs avec
les déclarations paille pour les
artisans avec la dématérialisation pour
les métiers du futur donc je ne
comprends pas que la région soit resté
les deux régions d'ailleurs y compris la
franche comté mais ça vaut pour la
bourgogne soit 7 très en retrait sur ce
sujet le premier un plan massif de
déploiement du très haut débit aux côtés
des départements on n'a rien entendu
christophe
vous faites quoi c'est à côté moi je
pense qu'il faut immédiatement rétablir
un lien entre la région et les trois
millions d'habitants de la région
pourquoi une franche comté aujourd'hui
la région c'est loin demain ça sera
encore plus loin avec la grande région
il faut qu'on a un lien direct pour que
les gens s'identifient leurs élus
régionaux aujourd'hui les connaissent
pas demain ils et connaîtront je
souhaite qu'il soit territorialisées
c'est à dire affecté à différentes
composantes de de labour une franche
comté et je souhaite également interrogé
en direct les habitants de la région
bourgogne franche comté sur les grandes
questions d'aménagement par leur
smartphone ou par d'autres
autre moyen de façon régulière ça sera
là la règle ça sera pas l'exception
je crois qu'avec cette action là on
permettra enfin d'avoir de vraies
relations entre la région et les gens
qui aujourd'hui s'identifie pas à ce
machin qui est très loin
sophie montel votre première décision de
présidente du conseil régional de
bourgogne
alors moi ma première décision gelée
annoncé le 24 septembre
si je suis élue présidente du conseil
régional bourgogne franche comté
j'annule immédiatement la délibération
du conseil régional qui vise à accorder
mille 1000 euros par place d'accueil
pour les migrants
voilà parce que ni la france ni la
franche comté la bourgogne n'ont
vocation à accueillir toute la misère du
monde nous avons en france plus de 5
millions de chômeurs nous avons neuf
millions de pauvres dont 3 millions
d'enfants
j'estime qu'en france il est normal que
les français soient maîtres chez eux et
soient prioritaires nathalie vermorel
quel serait votre première mesure parce
que je considère que dans ce pays qui
est très riche il ya largement les
moyens et d'accueillir les migrants et
faire vivre normalement et aisément les
familles populaires
la première mesure sur une mesure de
justice sociale pour pouvoir d'achat des
familles moi je souffre à la mise en
place de la tarification sociale dans
les cantines
l'extension à tous les apprentis de la
gratuité des trousse à outils et des
équipements et les transports scolaires
gratuits en prévision pour 2010 est mais
je dis comment je finance cette mesure
est gelée déjà dit au conseil régional
de bourgogne
je pense qu'il nous faut dans cette
période où nous allons encore perdre des
millions de dotations que l'état va pas
nous donner faire un moratoire sur les
intérêts d'emprunt des banques
aujourd'hui nous avons des emprunts à 2%
le pib est à 0,7 un prélèvement excessif
sur les richesses produites
donc nous demandons l'effort aux banques
et dans la foulée nous qu'on nous
convoquons une conférence financière une
conférence publique
pour discuter de ce que je venais de
dire les 62 milliards de dépôts c'est
notre argent
il est temps des baux dans les bols de
bourgogne franche comté nous devons
avoir notre mot à dire sur son
utilisation nous ne pouvons pas laisser
ça aux financiers mesures pour le
pouvoir d'achat donc c'est non on
veillera à l'égalité des territoires à
créer des liens de coopération et de pas
de subordination entre ville et campagne
en s'assurant une desserte équilibré de
tout le territoire par des transports
alternatifs à la voiture individuelle
mais qui favorise les déplacements
domicile travail domicile école domicile
dans les universités les déplacements du
quotidien donc on encouragera
l'autopartage le covoiturage les ter les
transports en commun les aménagements
cyclables sécurisées tout ça pour
permettre la diminution des gaz à effet
de serre et de lutter contre le
changement climatique
en même temps vague du feu alors
permettez moi avant de revenir sur la
proposition de françois sauvadet que je
trouve excellente parce que je la
partage complètement le très haut débit
c'est indispensable mais je n'en le sud
monsieur sauvadet
monsieur l'innovation la gauche
monsieur sauvadet une fois de plus vous
n'avez pas le droit de dire des choses
qui sont fausses
la région n'a pas été en retrait sur
l'investissement du très haut débit 70
millions entre les deux régions à
égalité quasiment avec chacun des
départements
donc je ne bave peuvent pas vous
entendre dire joueur a porté sur les
départements voir un jour rien dire est
ce que c'est que la côte d'or parce que
vous réagissez comme une élue de franche
comté
il faut mettre dans la peau d'une élue
qui se gorge vous souhaitez sur un
vernis de la jonquera
si on vous dernier a compté on aime voir
c'est un investissement substantiel et
la région et on rend d aller me première
mesure se sent très haut débit il n'y a
effectivement pas de développement
ma mesure la première mesure c'est un
service public de l'efficacité
énergétique la facture énergétique est
trop lourde pour les ménages pour la
réduire il faut faire des travaux des
travaux d'isolation pour ça il faut
pouvoir les payer
tout le monde ne peut pas les payer
alors il faut de la vigueur
tir de l'information de l'apport
technique de la garantie bancaire et des
financements
et tout cela quelles que soient les
ressources des uns et des autres il faut
le faire c'est pour cela que ma première
mesure ça sera de mettre en place un
service public pour tous de l'efficacité
énergétique
alors on va arriver au terme de cette
région très rapidement non mais d'autres
régions l'ont déjà fait or viendra
peut-être sur le prochaine émission
l'émission spéciale développement
économique peut-être
du coup on arrive au terme de cette
émission et on a choisi vous demander ce
que vous traitez dire aux électeurs qui
sont appelés aux urnes donc les 6 et 13
décembre prochains dans deux mois tout
juste on a fait un tirage au sort pour
cela et on commence avec vous sophie
montel vous avez une quarantaine de
secondes chaque version moi je voulais
dire aux téléspectateurs aux électeurs
et aux électrices qui nous regardent que
je crois qu'ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à être conscients des bilans
désastreux tant de l'ump et du parti
socialiste et ce tant au plan national
qu'au plan régionale départementale et
communale
alors surtout je veux leur dire n'ayez
pas peur parce que souvent on entend
dire monsieur sauvadet l'a dit tout à
l'heure que le front national c'était la
catastrophe les sauterelles allait
s'abattre sur terre et que on allait
avoir un tsunami
je veux te tiens à rassurer les
électeurs parce que nous avons quand
même gagné certaines villes au mois de
mars 2014 et que ces villes sont très
bien gérés et que quand on fait des
sondages parmi la population les
habitants de ces villes sont largement
plus satisfaits par les municipalités fn
qu'ils ne le sont dans les autres
communes alors moi ce que je vais leur
dire c'est que s'ils veulent plus de
justice sociale
s'il veut à laon finir avec les
gaspillages et les découvertes huerre et
bien il faut qu'ils votent front
national merci c'est vous nathalie
vermorel
le numéro un le numéro deux vient ce que
je voulais 11 - anneau à nos concitoyens
c'est que ils ont tendu à travers mes
interventions que pour nous il n'est pas
question de raser gratis et que à chaque
mesure correspond une recherche de
financement
une recherche de fonds et que cette
recherche de fonds de ce bien s'opposer
aux politiques d'austérité
donc moi je les je les enjoins à voter
pour la liste que je vais conduire qu
israël une liste de gauche une liste
rassemblé uni citoyenne sociale avec un
objectif de transformation sociale parce
qu'il faut donner du poids à ses options
dans la gauche parce que sans ça la
politique de gauche du conseil régional
ne sera pas suffisante
merci christophe grudler numéro 3 votre
conclusion s'il vous plaît écoutez je
voulais dire aux habitants de la région
bourgogne franche comté qu'entre la côte
d'or du président sauvadet candidat de
sarkozy entre la région franche comté de
menaces du feq candidat du parti
hollande il y à une troisième voie pour
ces élections
la voix du centre la voie que je porte
avec mes amis
une voix d'union qui nous donne
aujourd'hui trois millions de raisons de
vouloir s'occuper des gens dans sept
régions trois millions de raisons de
vouloir avoir une reprise économique des
idées pour l'emploi 3 millions de
raisons également pour voir rayonner
notre nouvelle région en france et en
europe
je dirais que je ne le fais pas pour moi
je le fais pour vous habitant de la
région bourgogne franche comté et nous
le faisons pour gagner ensemble faisons
gagner d'autres régions contre les
intérêts si les parisiens soient
sauvadet de conclure moi d'abord ce que
je souhaite c'est vraiment marqué
drummond pardon excusez moi si tu as
marqué frères excusez moi c'était une
rupture si je me trompe
votre conclusion variés du fait ma
conclusion c'est que la région de
franche comté est reconnu comme la
région qui a été la mieux gérée en
france donc c'est sur cette base là que
je souhaite prendre la responsabilité de
la bourgogne franche comté bien gérée
avoir une ambition nous avons construit
le tgv nous avons innové socialement en
lançant des expérimentations pour
protéger les salariés menacés par le
chômage et donc je veux demain en
bourgogne franche comté continue et cela
tout en appuyant sur des valeurs qui
sont des valeurs extrêmement identitaire
autour de la du de l'aptitude à la
coopération de l'aptitude au partage de
l'aptitude à l'innovation sociale qu'il
y a dans notre territoire
merci d'avoir respecté votre tard et
c'est enfin vous français ça va moi je
vais vous dire je voudrais une région en
grand une région qui renoue avec la
fierté de son histoire qui redeviennent
une grande région nationale grandes
régions d'europe pas une région
administrée petit bras comme celle qu'a
porté la présidente sortante qui
d'ailleurs souhaitable de la franche
comté alors
elle aspire à devenir présente pour
gagner franche comté et moi changement
de méthode aussi changement complet de
méthode d'abord travaillé avec des
acteurs locaux ceux qui font l'emploi
qui ont été souvent pas écouté ou peu
entendu être pragmatique c'est à dire
évaluer nos politiques arrêtés avec
cette suffisance politique qui dit quand
on a déterminé le politique c'est la
bonne moi je souhaite qu'on rentre dans
une ère de l'évaluation
et puis la troisième chose c'est une
région qui investissent dans les
stratégies d'avenir
on n'a pas le temps de parler de
l'aéroport moi j'en veux un pour la
région bourgogne franche comté en or l
ararat pendant les autres débats merci
françois sauvadet cécile prud'hommes
votre conclusion pour nous les
écologistes il ya trois notions
indissociables climat emploi solidarité
ces trois notions là ça nous permet
d'agir pour le bien-être et pour la
santé de chacun nous on va défendre
l'écologie au sens que l'écologie est un
hymne à la vie et qu'elle oeuvre pour la
santé et de la planète et enfin entre
guillemets et des personnes et je tiens
à dire aujourd'hui que la pollution de
l'air par exemple tu autant que le sida
et le paludisme réunis qui va falloir
s'empoigner du problème rapidement et
que seuls les écologistes proposent des
solutions pour répondre à cette question
merci beaucoup et merci à tous d'avoir
accepté notre invitation pour ce premier
débat vraiment lancé sûre pour les
prochaines régionales on peut préciser
j'ai remis que nous nous retrouverons
tous les samedis du mois de novembre
avec des débats thématiques dans la voix
est libre tous les samedis du mois
novembre à partir de 11 heures
oui merci à tous merci d'avoir suivi
cette émission profitez bien de votre
week-end sur france 3 franche comté et
france 3 bourgogne et puis on se
retrouve très vite pour parler de la
politique et de cette campagne des
élections régionales on n'oublie pas le
scrutin c'est les deux premiers
dimanches de décembre bonne fin de
week-end à tous merci